lots of chord changes and tunings in
this film and this life story why now
and why this team big answer big
question uh why now
it started off one way it wound up
another I'm at a stage in my life I'm 77
years old right I'm ancient and I'm
supposed to be walking off into the
sunset hand in hand but by a sweetheart
it's been good to know ya and I love
y'all so so long and didn't work out
that way for records in for years which
and I am kind of bragging but I don't
know I've I can't remember anybody else
doing that not a long time you know
somebody probably did but and I'm
halfway through a fifth way and that's
unusual it's not what was supposed to
happen and it's it's an aberration to
break in the normal flow it's not what
you expect and AJ's brother Marcus
wonderful guitar player fantastic
musician good singer-songwriter I had
been working with me and so he asked AJ
to come by no I hate chase a filmmaker
in his head he's well we spent a
filmmaker in the e says you know hmm
this isn't what I expected and I so that
was the initial impetus okay it's a it's
a an unusual circumstance and and
something maybe to look at no I have to
say hey Jake pestered me about it
repeatedly and I said yes your kid it's
just it's true
possibly the wrong answer over to you
Alphonse Wow
so AJ what are the milestones so to tell
us it's kind of a timeline how long and
what all you do to convince him well
Crosby was 69 years old and he you're 77
you're gonna be 78 in August 13th
correct
103
[Laughter]
and what cross says is true I had a
chance to go into this recording session
and what I saw and what I heard totally
defined all of my expectations you know
and the music was fresh and I was just
totally floored by what I saw and so I
said you know someone should shoot
footage of this in the minute that he
allowed me to shoot footage and come
into his sanctum into the recording
studio Batmen and I was like wow this is
pretty cool
because and I asked Crosby a couple of
questions on camera and he can tell a
damn good story so for a couple of years
I was begging and borrowing money to
shoot this footage because I felt like
everything he was doing was so worth
shooting and I couldn't afford not to
shoot it but I also couldn't afford to
shoot it so a couple of times I paid for
film crew and set it by rent and I
almost lost my apartment a couple of
times it was kind of like film problems
and but then I got to a point where I
had massed enough footage and then and I
needed to I needed to go and seek other
financing and I had a number of bizarre
Hollywood meetings with some agencies
that are like well you know he's a
has-been I'm like not quite you guys and
then another agency said you know we'll
finance it but we we would love to see
you incorporate one of our hip-hop
artists that we were and I'm like yeah
that's not gonna happen Crosby is not
gonna go for that
so I kind of got to a point where I was
like you know maybe this movie isn't
gonna be isn't made and Jill mazurski
she produces a great movie called keep
on keepin on I was so inspired by that
really great movie and I saw that and
she and I met a couple of times and and
I went to her office and I kind of was
just basically about ready to tell Jill
like I'm gonna move on just gonna take
this footage and put it in storage and
in the hallway at her office
I saw the movie music Oracle himself mr.
camford crow and I was like
lightning struck my brain that's it
why didn't I think about this earlier
and so Jill advocated on my behalf and
Cameron graciously agreed to meet with
me the next day and I remember him like
tapping on his yellow steno pad he's
like this is really cool I'm into this
and I'll give it to Cameron we were we
were working on a movie and our hit TV
series roadies I like this so I was kind
of like I did two one one smoking season
but anyway I talked to AJ and cross was
around and I just immediately put a fan
hat on because he's one of the great
storytellers as AJ said and interviews
that I had ever encountered and I just I
love spending time around him so I was
kind of the guy who said look I can't do
this you got to do it though and and I
think I just kind of shotgunned a lot of
fans stuff at the time which is like
don't get a lot of talking heads keep
the camera on cross Mike him really
warmly have him have his eyeline close
to the camera
make it like there's no middleman he's
talking to you a longtime friend that
maybe he even cares about and he's gonna
tell you everything and like just do it
like that in fact let me do your first
interview when the tentacles for and
wrap themselves around exactly the
minute these guys started talking and
and it's true that we were on the same
wavelength in the minute that we sat
down for this first interview it was a
groove masters in in Santa Monica at
Jackson Browne studio and the minute
these two started talking I was like oh
we're in for a wild ride and I said to
the camera crew us I could get more film
get more data cards right now because
don't mind me no but this is a 45 year
conversation going on right it's true
so you're capturing something that's
just a continuation and we feel it and
we're brought in but the filmmaking
becomes a part of the film can you talk
about sort of the structure of
we see on the screen and so all the
hours you capture but but what was the
editing process what was the story
construction process that we get to to
be a part of I'll just kick this off AJ
had a wonderful idea which is that the
story takes place in the course of
crosses tour and and he he's very good
about let's establish stakes so he said
you know it's tough when cross leaves
home people wonder what's gonna happen
when's he gonna come back maybe even is
he gonna come back you know and this is
this is what AJ was saying and so that
structure was established pretty early
on and then we just started spinning off
into various directions and and he was
so cooperative even even reluctantly a
few times like Laurel Canyon
yeah there's no cinematic value here
whatsoever
hahahahaha son of an Academy
award-winning cinematographer right
there yeah but he he he went with us for
that structure and the structure really
worked I thought that was like a
brilliant way to you to kind of form
something that we wanted to be different
from a classical kind of you know music
documentary where you're you're and I
think the movie works like this where
the first few minutes are going okay
yeah I know how it works
yeah pain Redemption wait a minute this
guy's a little more honest than I'm used
to people in a documentary like this
wait a minute now the bath has gotten
warmer and warmer and suddenly you're in
a hot Jacuzzi of honesty and that's kind
of the way we wanted the movie to like
take you in I feel like there's sort of
four generations in this room tonight so
your father because we're the Academy
you Cameron Crowe and AJ four
generations within this conversation but
you're you've been so generous with with
the younger creators for so long and
even now your collaborators are such
young vibrant sort of up-and-coming
folks he talked to us a bit about what
you think you give to them and what you
get from from these collaborations joy
if you work with young people uh you
have to paddle faster to keep up it's a
good thing
it stretches me pushes me which is
exactly right you the one thing you
don't want to do is lay back and relax
the minute you do that you've sort of
you start going downhill I I'm thrilled
with music I'm not thrilled but you know
what it feels like when the bus goes
over a pothole at 3 o'clock in the
morning yeah but I'm really love singing
and love I mean two really good bands
and everybody in them feels exactly the
same way I do they love it it's their
life and and we don't make a lot of
money in either one of those bands none
of us do not mean not that but we make
really explicitly good music and and I
forgot what the question was
thank you so much for this film on for
this piece of art and put this
incredible story and for all of your
music